the great school supply drive is
underway today rocky checked in with our
partners at the las vegas honda dealers
the sponsors of this segment to see how
things are going
happy day two of the great school supply
drive going through july 28th come on
down to your las vegas honda dealers and
bring your supplies in to benefit the
clark county school district tommy first
and foremost i have to start with you
because i just heard you have three
girls at home i do how important are
fresh school supplies to them more
important than toys dresses
any kid loves fresh school supplies and
my daughters love whether it be a fresh
glue stick or a fresh set of markers
there's nothing better than fresh school
supplies that's too cute i grew up
wanting fresh school supplies as well so
that's why it's so important for every
kid to have that opportunity so why do
the las vegas honda dealers you know are
why are you guys involved in this school
supply drive so honda's synonymous with
family and nothing more important to our
family than our children so we knew
there was an opportunity to get involved
and help the community and everybody
agreed uh unanimously to step up and and
help raise some supplies for our city
well your customers so far have done a
great job look at that backpack this is
how the kids express themselves this is
so important highlighter what are people
bringing in scissors
tape crayons anything and everything you
used when you were in school all the
same stuff still applies even old-school
pencils that's your old school pencils
for those standardized testing
okay and you know when they walk into
the las vegas honda dealers you know do
you make it pretty obvious you have a
box right in front of the door we should
have a box every dealer will have a box
in the front of the dealership near the
entrance uh with uh with the indication
on the front of it hopefully you'll see
a bunch of school supplies overflowing
like this stack these boxes
now how many how many honda dealers do
we have around town so we have four
honda dealers we have um finley honda in
the north okay we have honda west we
have autonation honda in the east and
then finley honda and henderson perfect
and when they walk in you know what is
the ultimate experience here besides the
besides the school supplies well we
expect everybody's greeted with smiling
faces and people willing to help
obviously we've got a comfortable
waiting lobby we've got amenities snacks
coffee drinks um and a comfortable
lounge to wait if you need to okay so
come on down to your las vegas honda
dealers yeah donate your school supplies
for the kids and i don't know maybe get
your car serviced yeah if you're on your
way down to get your car serviced make
sure to stop and pick up some school
supplies to help the kids of our city
absolutely well thank you so much tommy
for all that you guys are doing for the
community you guys are have until the
28th to donate to our kids around clark
county i'll send it back to you
eight news now is partnering with
smith's and las vegas honda dealers to
collect school supplies for our
community starting today you can drop
off backpacks folders pencils and other
items to your nearby smith's location or
las vegas honda dealer this runs through
july 28th there's more information at
eightnewsnow.com